Alice:Lucy啊你在吗
Alice: Lucia, are you there?
Lucia: 我在二楼
Lucia: I'm on the second floor.
Alice:我来帮你吧
Alice: Let me help you.
Alice:没有哎
Alice: It's not here.
Alice:那你那个不好用的剪刀呢
Alice: Where's that pair of bad scissors?
Alice:你找到了吗
Alice: Did you find it?
Lucia: 不好用的那个没有
Lucia: The bad one isn't here.
Lucia: 我只在快递桌上找到了这个
Lucia: I only found this one on the delivery table.
Lucia: 就是昨天晚上我用的那个
Lucia: The one I used last night.
Alice:哎，这不是么
Alice: This is...
Lucia: 哎可以的可以的
Lucia: Oh, it works, it works.
Lucia: 对对对就是那个
Lucia: Yes, that's the one.
Lucia: 那可能是昨天宇轩在楼上用了这个
Lucia: Maybe Rain used this one upstairs yesterday.
Alice:你的吗
Alice: Is it yours?
Lucia: 不是我的
Lucia: It's not mine.
Lucia: 这是宇轩的
Lucia: It's Rain's.
Alice:是啥呀
Alice: What is it?
Lucia: 他是想做一个风铃
Lucia: He wants to make a wind chime.
Lucia: 他还没做完应该
Lucia: He hasn't finished yet, I think.
Lucia: 不过我我跟他确实有个很像的配件
Lucia: But I do have a similar part.
Lucia: 看我这还没有把它拆下来做装饰
Lucia: Look, I haven't taken it apart for decoration yet.
Alice:这个好像那个含香头上戴的那个
Alice: This looks like what Hanxiang wears on her head.
Lucia: 啊是对对对
Lucia: Ah yes, exactly.
Alice:香妃
Alice: Xiangfei.
Lucia: 因为我这个珠子
Lucia: Because these beads...
Lucia: 打算等欧根纱到了再用
Lucia: I'm planning to use them when the organza arrives.
Alice:欧根纱到了吗
Alice: Has the organza arrived?
Alice:今天可以做吗
Alice: Can we do it today?
Lucia: 到了
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia: 总感觉我给自己挖了一个很大的坑
Lucia: I feel like I've dug myself a big hole.
Alice:你你这个有镭射的感觉好看
Alice: Your thing has a laser-like look, it's pretty.
Lucia: 对是的它镀了膜
Lucia: Yes, it’s coated.
Lucia: 可以帮我把这些都剪下来吗
Lucia: Can you help me cut these out?
Lucia: 就是嗯我看我怎么跟你解释一下
Lucia: Just, um, let me explain.
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh no.
Lucia: 这样就比较好搞
Lucia: This way, it’s easier to handle.
Lucia: 就是你看它其实每个每个贴画
Lucia: See, each sticker is originally like this.
Lucia: 它本来是这样的
Lucia: It’s like this.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Mm-hmm.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia: 然后但因为就是不敢这样往墙上贴嘛
Lucia: But I can’t stick it on the wall like this.
Lucia: 然后
Lucia: So...
Lucia: 所以我就是沿着它这个边给它剪下来
Lucia: I cut along the edge.
Lucia: 也不用剪的特别齐
Lucia: It doesn’t need to be cut perfectly.
Lucia: 就是只要这个画在上面就行
Lucia: As long as the picture is on it, it’s fine.
Lucia: 然后对就我到时候用美文纸往上一贴
Lucia: Then I’ll stick it on with adhesive tape.
Lucia: 谢谢你因为这个工作量真的有点大
Lucia: Thank you, because this is a lot of work.
Lucia: 你看我已经剪了一个
Lucia: Look, I’ve already cut one.
Alice:但如果我剪的不是特别顺呢
Alice: What if I don’t cut it very neatly?
Lucia: 呃没事
Lucia: Uh, it’s okay.
Alice:没关系画只要画在上就行
Alice: It’s fine as long as the picture is on it.
Lucia: 只要画在上面就行
Lucia: As long as the picture is on it, it’s fine.
Alice:那直接按照这个缝剪得了
Alice: Then I’ll just cut along this seam.
Lucia: 对对对就按那个份剪
Lucia: Yes, just cut along that seam.
Lucia: 然后你偏一点或者怎么样都没关系的
Lucia: It doesn’t matter if you go a bit off.
Lucia: 因为反正只是大概的用一下
Lucia: We just need it roughly done.
Lucia: 现在已经没有空间
Lucia: There's no space left now.
Lucia: 就是让我们再去进行一些
Lucia: It's like we're being forced to do more.
Lucia: 强迫症的就是完美主义
Lucia: It's an obsessive-compulsive perfectionism thing.
Alice:我懂你的意思
Alice: I get what you mean.
Lucia: 了啊
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 每次都会感激的要感到崩溃
Lucia: Every time I feel grateful to the point of breaking down.
Lucia: 谢谢可心
Lucia: Thanks, Kexin.
Alice:51之后还会再录一期吗
Alice: Are we going to record another episode after 51?
Lucia: 呃不知道
Lucia: Uh, I don't know.
Lucia: 也有可能
Lucia: Maybe.
Lucia: 有可能只是靖康他们在开玩笑
Lucia: Maybe Jingkang and the others are just joking.
Lucia: 因为那个呃
Lucia: Because, um,
Lucia: 就是薇薇说他们那边就是三亚那边
Lucia: Vivi said that over in Sanya,
Lucia: 房子租金很便宜很便宜
Lucia: the rent for houses is really cheap.
Alice:确实
Alice: True.
Lucia: 就是咱们这个不是租一天要1,500吗
Lucia: Unlike here where it costs 1,500 a day to rent.
Lucia: 不愧是北京啊
Lucia: Typical Beijing.
Alice:我打算
Alice: I'm planning
Alice:我打算去大理旅游一个月旅居一个月
Alice: I'm planning to travel and stay in Dali for a month.
Lucia: 哇我我可以申请和你一起去吗
Lucia: Wow, can I apply to go with you?
Alice:但是我还得看那个
Alice: But I still need to check,
Alice:因为我学校也不是完全能走脱
Alice: because my school isn't completely free.
Alice:然后我现在打算
Alice: And now I'm planning,
Lucia: 出去玩可以找我
Lucia: If you want to go out, you can find me.
Lucia: 我在理论上说
Lucia: I mean, in theory,
Lucia: 我在今年8月之前应该整体安排
Lucia: I should have everything arranged by August this year.
Alice:你是
Alice: You are...
Lucia: 都不是很忙
Lucia: Not very busy.
Lucia: 就是时间会相对自由一些
Lucia: My time will be relatively free.
Lucia: 除非有一些会什么的之类要开
Lucia: Unless there's some meeting or something.
Lucia: 就学校的那种
Lucia: Like school stuff.
Lucia: 所以如果出去玩可以找大理
Lucia: So if you want to go out, you can find Dali.
Lucia: 我也没去过
Lucia: I haven't been there either.
Alice:大理是个很美的城市
Alice: Dali is a beautiful city.
Lucia: 国内很多地方都没有去
Lucia: There are many places in the country I haven't visited.
Lucia: 如果他们接下来要在三亚搞也挺好的
Lucia: If they are going to do something in Sanya next, that would be great.
Lucia: 我就继续报名
Lucia: I'll continue to sign up.
Lucia: 因为三亚我也没去过
Lucia: Because I've never been to Sanya either.
Alice:只不过就是很热
Alice: It's just really hot there.
Alice:但是我们不怎么外出的话
Alice: But if we don't go out much...
Alice:只是费点电而已
Alice: It just uses a bit of electricity.
Lucia: 我觉得按照咱们这次的这个安排
Lucia: I think according to our plan this time,
Lucia: 看在不是很会经常外出
Lucia: since we don't go out that often...
Alice:想听歌露西
Alice: Want to listen to some music, Lucia?
Alice:我放一首歌吧
Alice: Let me play a song.
Alice:你听中文吗
Alice: Do you listen to Chinese songs?
Lucia: 我没事都可以听
Lucia: I can listen to anything, it's fine.
Alice:我喜欢听这个
Alice: I like listening to this.
Lucia: 我只是因为
Lucia: It's just because...
Lucia: 我自己比较喜欢的那几个歌手
Lucia: I personally like a few singers,
Lucia: 是外国的
Lucia: and they're foreign.
Lucia: 所以我就听欧美的听得多一些
Lucia: So, I listen to more Western music.
Lucia: 但是其实只是听的话
Lucia: But actually, just for listening,
Lucia: 我什么都可以听
Lucia: I can listen to anything.
Lucia: 耶
Lucia: Yay.
Lucia: 我觉得我小装饰好像买太少了
Lucia: I think I bought too few little decorations.
Lucia: 我当时害怕到不了
Lucia: I was afraid they wouldn't arrive,
Lucia: 觉得没有必要买那么多
Lucia: so I thought there was no need to buy too many.
Lucia: 现在看来
Lucia: Now it seems like
Lucia: 可能会导致那个房间稍微有点单调
Lucia: it might make the room a bit plain.
Alice:我当时本来有很多想买的小东西
Alice: I originally had a lot of small things I wanted to buy,
Alice:但我后来想
Alice: but then I thought,
Alice:我们的预算有限
Alice: our budget is limited,
Alice:然后那种小的可能看不见
Alice: and those small things might not be noticeable.
Alice:然后我就买了大件的那个床单被罩
Alice: So I bought bigger items like bed sheets and duvet covers,
Alice:然后窗帘这种
Alice: and curtains.
Lucia: 我的有一个很重要的预算
Lucia: One important part of my budget
Lucia: 花在我买了一个小塑料柜上
Lucia: went into buying a small plastic cabinet.
Lucia: 虽然那个它也不是很贵
Lucia: Even though it wasn't very expensive,
Lucia: 但是
Lucia: but
Lucia: 因为我那个房间不是没有小小桌子
Lucia: because my room didn't have a small table,
Alice:对
Alice: Right.
Lucia: 它是一个特别丑的架子
Lucia: it's a really ugly shelf.
Lucia: 你来看真的很丑
Lucia: You'll see, it's really ugly.
Alice:给搁这
Alice: Put it here.
Lucia: 我房间现还有点还有点乱就是
Lucia: My room is still a bit messy now.
Alice:你当初
Alice: At first,
Alice:为什么一开始就想选这个房间呢
Alice: why did you choose this room?
Lucia: 我想选二楼的
Lucia: I wanted to pick the second floor.
Lucia: 然后随便就随便进了一个
Lucia: Then I just randomly went into one.
Lucia: 因为我对就他很丑
Lucia: Because I think it's really ugly.
Alice:这个是架子吗对
Alice: Is this a shelf?
Lucia: 所以我就买了一个那个小柜
Lucia: So I bought a small cabinet.
Lucia: 到时候我就把这个搬出去嗯
Lucia: I'll move this out later.
Alice:啊你的渔网
Alice: Oh, your fishing net.
Alice:小写生活大写爱
Alice: Small life, big love.
Lucia: 后那边
Lucia: Over there.
Lucia: 理论上
Lucia: Theoretically.
Lucia: 用欧根纱做一个海浪形状的装饰
Lucia: Use organza to make a wave-shaped decoration.
Lucia: 假如今天还来得及的话
Lucia: If we have time today.
Alice:是呢这样一铺就好多了
Alice: Yeah, it looks much better like this.
Lucia: 然后这个架子
Lucia: And this shelf.
Lucia: 下午我就把它搬到客厅去放着
Lucia: I'll move it to the living room this afternoon.
Lucia: 然后这个其实我有点想再往这边拿
Lucia: Actually, I kind of want to move it here.
Alice:哎你的欧根纱多不多啊
Alice: Hey, do you have much organza?
Lucia: 呃估计不是很多
Lucia: Uh, probably not much.
Lucia: 我好像买了一米半
Lucia: I think I bought one and a half meters.
Lucia: 你要干嘛
Lucia: What do you want to do?
Alice:欧根纱往这边缠一缠是不是也会
Alice: If we wrap some organza around here, wouldn't it also be nice?
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Alice:就是显得也还好
Alice: It would look okay.
Lucia: 没事这个直接拿出去
Lucia: No worries, just take this out.
Lucia: 到时候嘿嘿
Lucia: Then, hehe.
Alice:我的小礼物
Alice: My little gift.
Lucia: 我打算把它挂在这个网上
Lucia: I'm planning to hang it on this net.
Alice:这个吗
Alice: This one?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Yeah.
Alice:也挺好
Alice: That's good too.
Lucia: 形成一个时光墙的感觉哈哈
Lucia: It creates a time wall vibe, haha.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Alice:你是不是不怎么带装饰
Alice: You don't wear much decoration, do you?
Lucia: 呃哪个装饰哦
Lucia: Uh, which decoration?
Lucia: 你说我哦
Lucia: You mean me?
Alice:你的极简主义
Alice: Your minimalist style.
Lucia: 你说平常没有不是我也带
Lucia: You mean usually? No, I do wear some.
Lucia: 但是就是出门的话我会觉得很麻烦
Lucia: But when going out, I find it troublesome.
Lucia: 然后因为
Lucia: And because...
Lucia: 尤其咱们在这里住几天嘛
Lucia: Especially since we're staying here for a few days.
Lucia: 然后我就会觉得很麻烦
Lucia: I find it very troublesome.
Lucia: 我就不怎么带了
Lucia: So I don't wear much.
Lucia: 我在家的话会带
Lucia: When I'm at home, I'll bring it
Lucia: 因为我总会觉得就是我要是带了
Lucia: Because I always feel that if I bring it
Lucia: 我还得就是关注着他
Lucia: I have to keep an eye on it
Lucia: 比如说什么洗脸啊或者什么的
Lucia: Like when washing my face or something
Alice:是的我干什么这个
Alice: Yes, when I do this
Lucia: 有时候我可能
Lucia: Sometimes I might
Alice:我就不想让他碰到水
Alice: I just don't want it to get wet
Lucia: 对然后可能个别的时候很需要摘它
Lucia: Yeah, and sometimes you really need to take it off
Lucia: 但你摘了你要专门寄然后放在哪里了
Lucia: But once you take it off, you need to store it properly
Alice:是的
Lucia: 给它带盒子什么的然后
Lucia: Put it in a case or something
Lucia: 我觉得很麻烦
Lucia: I find it troublesome
Lucia: 我就不带
Lucia: So I don't bring it
Lucia: 我这人特别懒
Lucia: I'm really lazy
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 你你可能都没有见过比我更懒的人了
Lucia: You probably haven't met anyone lazier than me
Lucia: 真的
Lucia: Really
Alice:懒人有懒福
Alice: Lazy people have their own luck
Lucia: 我真的超级懒
Lucia: I'm really super lazy
Lucia: 然后就导致我每次干事情都都会
Lucia: Which means I always do things at the last minute
Lucia: 都会凑到DDL的时候干
Lucia: Always right before the deadline
Alice:我现在觉得很多事情是注定
Alice: I think many things are predestined
Lucia: 一定程度上确实
Lucia: To some extent, that's true
Lucia: 我觉得像这种小的
Lucia: For small things like this
Lucia: 我都可以直接直接粘
Lucia: I can just stick it directly
Lucia: 我把它在某个纸上那样先粘一下
Lucia: I'll stick it on some paper first
Lucia: 然后撕下来
Lucia: Then peel it off
Lucia: 它的胶性就会变弱
Lucia: The adhesive will become weaker
Alice:哇会呀
Alice: Wow, really?
Lucia: 就像这种海浪的纸
Lucia: Just like this wave-patterned paper
Alice:（歌词）我会永远爱你
Alice: (Lyrics) I will always love you
Lucia: 对这个星星我就那样子刷
Lucia: For this star, I just brush it like this
Alice:我去西安的话我去找你玩吧
Alice: If I go to Xi'an, I'll come visit you
Lucia: 可以呀来来来
Lucia: Sure, come, come, come
Lucia: 你什么时候来
Lucia: When are you coming?
Alice:我可能还要去找一下我朋友
Alice: I might need to visit my friend too
Alice:他在好像不在西安
Alice: He seems to not be in Xi'an
Alice:还在吗哎不在吧
Alice: Is he still there? Oh, maybe not
Lucia: 前段时间
Lucia: Recently
Lucia: 我有一个小伙伴刚来西安找过我
Lucia: A friend of mine just visited me in Xi'an
Alice:在西北农林西北农林在咸阳
Alice: At Northwest A&F University, it's in Xianyang
Lucia: 不太了解
Lucia: Not really sure.
Alice:西北农林科技
Alice: Northwest A&F University.
Lucia: 我其实一般也就在我们家附近那边
Lucia: I usually just stay around my neighborhood.
Lucia: 而且
Lucia: And
Lucia: 因为就是我上学期没有在西安上班
Lucia: Because last semester I wasn't working in Xi'an.
Lucia: 所以感觉有的地方也不是特别的熟
Lucia: So, I don't really know some places that well.
Lucia: 他们那边现在像北京一样
Lucia: Over there, it's like Beijing now.
Lucia: 就是专门在有一个区北边
Lucia: There's a specific area in the north.
Lucia: 那是什么区啊
Lucia: What's that area called?
Alice:什么呀
Alice: What?
Lucia: 那边就是在就是比较远的一个区
Lucia: It's a pretty far district.
Lucia: 给很多学校盖了分校
Lucia: They built a lot of branch schools there.
Lucia: 觉得就很麻烦
Lucia: I think it's very inconvenient.
Lucia: 把学生搞那么远地方去上学
Lucia: Sending students to such a far place for school.
Lucia: 一点体验都没有
Lucia: There's no experience at all.
Lucia: 下午还要叠被子
Lucia: I still have to fold the quilt this afternoon.
Lucia: 可是为什么你的卧室那么整齐
Lucia: But why is your bedroom so tidy?
Lucia: 你把行李放在哪里了哈哈哈
Lucia: Where did you put your luggage? Haha.
Alice:行李箱里面
Alice: In the suitcase.
Lucia: 我现在有点后悔我带的行李有点多
Lucia: I'm starting to regret bringing so much luggage.
Lucia: 我怕冷我带了我就多带了外套
Lucia: I was afraid of the cold, so I brought more jackets.
Lucia: 但是到了以后发现其实也不冷
Lucia: But after arriving, I realized it's actually not that cold.
Lucia: 实际上并不冷
Lucia: It's actually not cold at all.
Alice:完美
Alice: Perfect.
Lucia: 啊好看
Lucia: Ah, looks good.
Lucia: 我刚才也捡了一个海鸥
Lucia: I just picked up a seagull too.
Alice:这个你剪完了
Alice: Did you finish this one?
Lucia: 对这个因为比较大
Lucia: Yeah, because it's pretty big.
Lucia: 然后如果你觉得有需要
Lucia: And if you think it's necessary,
Lucia: 就是修的边可以修一修
Lucia: you can trim the edges a bit.
Alice:没关系
Alice: It's okay.
Lucia: 因为那个是昨天
Lucia: Because that one was from yesterday.
Lucia: 其实我没有找到剪刀
Lucia: Actually, I didn't find the scissors.
Lucia: 就是那个那个不太好用的蓝剪刀
Lucia: The blue scissors weren't very good.
Lucia: 雨轩当时在做那个分离
Lucia: Yuxuan was doing the separation then.
Lucia: 然后我就就是顺手用手撕了一下
Lucia: So I just tore it by hand.
Lucia: 因为反正当时咱们坐在这开会
Lucia: Since we were having a meeting anyway.
Lucia: 也没事干嘛
Lucia: Nothing much to do.
Lucia: 啊我还
Lucia: Oh, I still
Lucia: 我的预算还花在一个小玩偶上
Lucia: spent part of my budget on a small toy.
Lucia: 我买了一只蓝色的小鸟
Lucia: I bought a blue bird.
Lucia: 也是jellycat的
Lucia: It's also from Jellycat.
Lucia: 不过会便宜一些
Lucia: But it's a bit cheaper.
Lucia: 因为它体积比较小
Lucia: Because it's smaller in size.
Alice:你们是不是都比较喜欢杰力凯特
Alice: Do you guys all really like Jellycat?
Alice:Jellycat它的吸引力在哪里
Alice: What’s the appeal of Jellycat?
Alice:我不我不是质疑我就是单纯的疑问
Alice: I’m not questioning, just genuinely curious.
Lucia: 哦他比较可爱吧
Lucia: Oh, it's pretty cute, I guess.
Lucia: 然后我家里其实有一个他的小狗
Lucia: And actually, I have one of their puppies at home.
Lucia: 就我当时买的时候
Lucia: When I bought it,
Lucia: 它现在还没有现在这么火
Lucia: it wasn't as popular as it is now.
Lucia: 我当时在英国
Lucia: I was in the UK at the time,
Lucia: 然后是它出了一个柯基小狗的玩具
Lucia: and they released a Corgi puppy toy.
Lucia: 我觉得很可爱
Lucia: I thought it was really cute.
Lucia: 我在那个哈罗德逛街
Lucia: I was shopping at Harrods,
Lucia: 因为哈罗德东西太贵了我买不起
Lucia: but everything there was too expensive for me.
Lucia: 然后就只有玩具还便宜一点
Lucia: So the only thing I could afford was the toy.
Lucia: 我就买了一个
Lucia: So I bought one.
Lucia: 那个小狗真的挺软的
Lucia: That puppy is really soft.
Lucia: 挺舒服的
Lucia: Very comfy.
Lucia: 但我觉得这个鸟
Lucia: But I think this bird,
Lucia: 可能是因为它小的缘故
Lucia: maybe because it's smaller,
Lucia: 就是它手感没有那个小狗好
Lucia: doesn't feel as good as the puppy.
Lucia: 就是但是我买它是因为它是蓝色的
Lucia: But I bought it because it's blue.
Lucia: 就是它是蓝白相间那种颜色
Lucia: It's got a blue and white color scheme.
Lucia: 然后把床铺好之后往床上一放
Lucia: And once I make the bed and put it on,
Lucia: 就算是我装饰过床了
Lucia: it feels like I've decorated the bed.
Lucia: 因为我实在是找不到好看的床罩
Lucia: Because I really can't find a nice bedspread.
Lucia: 我本来还想就是买一个
Lucia: I originally wanted to buy one,
Lucia: 就是那个宾馆的那种
Lucia: like the ones in hotels.
Lucia: 就是那样一条的那个东西
Lucia: You know, the strip they put on the bed.
Lucia: 我也不知道它叫什么
Lucia: I don't know what it's called.
Lucia: 就是每就是每次去住宾馆
Lucia: Every time you stay in a hotel,
Alice:呃
Alice: Uh...
Lucia: 他还不是给你铺好床
Lucia: they make the bed for you.
Lucia: 他会还在上面放一个一条
Lucia: And they put that strip on top.
Alice:那个那个押押押金哎不知道
Alice: That, uh, deposit thing, I don't know.
Lucia: 对对对就就就是那个东西
Lucia: Yes, yes, that's the thing.
Lucia: 对反正你反正你肯定get到了
Lucia: Anyway, you got it.
Lucia: 就那个东西然后
Lucia: That thing, and then...
Alice:我一直不知道那个东西是干啥的
Alice: I never knew what that thing was for.
Lucia: 我也不知道那用来干啥的
Lucia: I don't know what it's for either.
Alice:但是反正好看一点
Alice: But at least it looks nice.
Lucia: 对我本来是想买一个蓝色那个东西
Lucia: Yeah, I originally wanted to buy a blue one.
Lucia: 但是我发现
Lucia: But I found out
Lucia: 连那个好看的颜色都很难找
Lucia: that even the nice colors are hard to find.
Lucia: 就
Lucia: Just
Lucia: 我本来想哪怕是就是克莱因蓝也可以
Lucia: I even thought a Klein blue would be okay.
Lucia: 虽然饱和度高一点
Lucia: Even though it's a bit more saturated.
Lucia: 但是就整体它的色调上
Lucia: But overall, in terms of the tone,
Lucia: 我觉得还是还是那个
Lucia: I think it still fits.
Lucia: 就是相符的
Lucia: But I couldn't find it either.
Lucia: 但也没找到
Lucia: So I just gave up.
Lucia: 然后我就就放弃了
Lucia: Then I just gave up.
Alice:你要是用加装的标准来找
Alice: If you look for it with home decor standards,
Alice:那就是基本是没的
Alice: it's basically not gonna happen.
Alice:然后你可以搜关键词的时候
Alice: Instead, you can search for keywords like
Alice:可以搜摆拍道具啊
Alice: props for photo shoots.
Alice:就是非家装的就会给你推一些
Alice: If it's not home decor, they'll suggest some things for you.
Lucia: 我的我的镭射纸就是摆拍道具
Lucia: My laser paper is just a prop for photo shoots.
Lucia: 希望他一会好用
Lucia: Hope it works well later.
Lucia: 啊好有道理
Lucia: Ah, that makes sense.
Lucia: 对打开道具我想赶快把这弄完
Lucia: Yeah, open the props, I want to finish this quickly.
Lucia: 这样
Lucia: So
Lucia: 我就可以把我的那个小水母做出来了
Lucia: I can make my little jellyfish.
Lucia: 虽然今天他没有灯
Lucia: Even though it doesn't have lights today.
Lucia: 但是呢啊
Lucia: But, uh
Alice:你们比较喜欢我这种人吗
Alice: Do you guys like people like me?
Alice:啊你们比较喜欢我这种人吗
Lucia: 为什么会不喜欢呢
Lucia: Why wouldn't we like you?
Lucia: 我有好几个小伙伴都是EFP
Lucia: I have several friends who are EFP.
Lucia: 而且我觉得你跟我一个朋友很像
Lucia: And I think you resemble one of my friends a lot.
Alice:NFP吗
Alice: NFP?
Lucia: 就很对就很可爱
Lucia: Yes, very much so, very cute.
Lucia: 然后很怎么形容
Lucia: And very, how should I describe it,
Lucia: 就很很work然后很很helpful的感觉
Lucia: very hardworking and helpful.
Lucia: 谁会不喜欢呢
Lucia: Who wouldn't like that?
Lucia: 我觉得我们这种自闭I人才比较
Lucia: I think we introverted people
Lucia: 才比较担心
Lucia: are more worried
Lucia: 就是就是别人喜不喜欢的问题
Lucia: about whether others like us or not.
Lucia: 因为感觉你们就是很热情
Lucia: Because I feel like you guys are very enthusiastic.
Lucia: 所以大家肯定都会喜欢的
Lucia: So everyone will definitely like it.
Alice:我以前觉得被人喜欢很重要
Alice: I used to think being liked was very important.
Alice:现在觉得被讨厌很正常
Alice: Now I think being disliked is normal.
Lucia: 哎我以前也觉得别人喜欢很重要
Lucia: Yeah, I used to think being liked by others was very important too.
Lucia: 但因为我是个i人
Lucia: But because I'm a melancholic person,
Lucia: 然后所以就是我觉得好像我也很难
Lucia: I feel like it's also very hard for me.
Lucia: 就是特别特别特别
Lucia: It's just particularly, particularly, particularly...
Alice:你的自我内心是很坚定的
Alice: You have a very strong inner self.
Alice:其实E人有的时候
Alice: Actually, sometimes extroverts...
Alice:对外界的反馈依赖感太强了
Alice: They rely too much on external feedback.
Alice:所以反而会
Alice: So instead, it becomes...
Lucia: 然后后来我就哎算了这个强求不来
Lucia: Then later I thought, well, it's not something you can force.
Alice:确实
Alice: Indeed.
Lucia: 我昨天晚上还在想
Lucia: I was still thinking last night,
Lucia: 今天活动我要不要带你送的那个手链
Lucia: Whether I should wear the bracelet you gave me to today's event.
Alice:戴上吗
Alice: Are you going to wear it?
Lucia: 好的那我下午就带上
Lucia: Okay, then I'll wear it this afternoon.
Lucia: 这样就形成一个密切的集体感
Lucia: This way, it creates a sense of close-knit group.
Alice:那个朱砂我给我最好的朋友也买了
Alice: I also bought that cinnabar for my best friend.
Lucia: 很好看很好看
Lucia: It's very beautiful, very beautiful.
Lucia: 谢谢可心
Lucia: Thank you, Kexin.
Alice:也买了一条
Alice: I bought one for him too.
Alice:就是这是我送给他的新年礼物
Alice: It's my New Year's gift to him.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: 好看的真的很好看
Lucia: It's really beautiful, truly beautiful.
Alice:因为他本命年了嘛
Alice: Because it's his zodiac year.
Alice:然后我就想着送他一个
Alice: So I thought of giving him something like this.
Alice:就是这种辟邪的东西
Alice: Something that wards off evil.
Alice:然后后来他他姥姥看见了
Alice: Then later, his grandma saw it.
Alice:然后他就觉得
Alice: And she thought...
Alice:他姥姥也觉得那个手链很好
Alice: His grandma thought the bracelet was great.
Alice:然后寓意也好
Alice: And it had good meaning.
Alice:然后他他又托我买一条
Alice: Then she asked me to buy another one.
Alice:然后我就给他姥姥也买了一条
Alice: So I bought one for his grandma too.
Lucia: 人见人爱
Lucia: Loved by everyone.
Lucia: 这个这个
Lucia: This, this...
Lucia: 一会再弄他
Lucia: I'll deal with it later.
Lucia: 我小时候特别想给自己家床上
Lucia: When I was little, I really wanted to make my bed at home...
Lucia: 不是自己家床上
Lucia: Not on my own bed at home...
Lucia: 说啥呢我自己家墙上贴这个
Lucia: What are you talking about? I put this on my own wall.
Lucia: 就是墙贴
Lucia: It's just a wall sticker.
Lucia: 让我爸妈觉
Lucia: My parents think
Lucia: 得墙贴不好收拾
Lucia: that wall stickers are hard to clean.
Lucia: 因为就有的墙贴如果你贴时间久了
Lucia: Because if you leave them on for too long,
Lucia: 他就不好撕嘛
Lucia: they become hard to peel off.
Lucia: 然后撕下来他可能就有那种黑印子
Lucia: And when you peel them off, they can leave black marks.
Lucia: 我爸妈比较洁癖
Lucia: My parents are kind of neat freaks.
Lucia: 也不能算是洁癖
Lucia: Well, not exactly neat freaks.
Lucia: 就是他们比较喜欢房间整齐一点
Lucia: They just like the room to be tidy.
Lucia: 然后我就一直没有贴过好可惜
Lucia: So I never put them up, which is a shame.
Lucia: 这次也不能贴
Lucia: And I can't put them up this time either.
Lucia: 好可惜只能拿美纹纸贴一下
Lucia: It's a pity, I can only use masking tape.
Lucia: 不过我觉得美纹纸还行
Lucia: But I think masking tape is okay.
Lucia: 还挺好用的
Lucia: It's quite useful.
Alice:我小时候把我们家所有的家具上
Alice: When I was little, I wrote "11" on all our furniture
Alice:都用我妈的口红写了一个十一
Alice: with my mom's lipstick.
Lucia: 啊为什么呢
Lucia: Oh, why?
Alice:我
Alice: I...
Lucia: 为什么是11呢
Lucia: Why "11"?
Alice:已经不记得了
Alice: I don't remember.
Alice:但我就是把所有家具上面都画了个11
Alice: But I just drew "11" on all the furniture.
Alice:所有哈哈
Alice: On everything, haha.
Alice:毕竟我们家还是那种木
Alice: And we had wooden furniture.
Alice:呃实木家具
Alice: Real wood furniture.
Alice:就是那种
Alice: So,
Alice:反正就是口红画上去
Alice: once the lipstick was on,
Alice:就基本别想弄掉了
Alice: it was almost impossible to remove.
Lucia: 怎么听起来好像哈哈
Lucia: That sounds so funny, haha.
Alice:我我小时候还点房子呢点火
Alice: I even set the house on fire once.
Alice:在我把我家墙烧的黢黑
Alice: I burned our walls black.
Alice:然后小时候虎了吧唧的
Alice: I was such a reckless kid.
Alice:我还偷邻居家的花
Alice: I even stole flowers from the neighbors.
Alice:其实我当时没想要偷
Alice: I didn't mean to steal them.
Alice:我就觉得那么好看
Alice: I just thought they were pretty.
Alice:我就想让它离我近一点
Alice: I wanted them closer to me.
Alice:然后我就把它拿了种在我家
Alice: So I took them and planted them in our yard.
Alice:种在我家的花坛里
Alice: In our flower bed.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 我小时候试图抓过邻居家的鸽子
Lucia: I once tried to catch the neighbor's pigeons when I was little.
Lucia: 但我们
Lucia: But we
Lucia: 我们家邻居没有花花
Lucia: Our neighbors don't have flowers
Lucia: 我爸在阳台上养过花花
Lucia: My dad used to grow flowers on the balcony
Lucia: 后来他也不养
Lucia: But later he stopped
Lucia: 他嫌麻烦
Lucia: He thought it was too much trouble
Alice:这个空白就不给你剪了吧
Alice: I won't cut this blank part for you
Alice:你直接这样一整一个整体
Alice: Just keep it as a whole piece
Lucia: 可以可以
Lucia: Sure, sure
Lucia: 希望他放在墙上没有那个啥
Lucia: I hope when he puts it on the wall it won't be
Lucia: 因为他这个底本来是透明的
Lucia: Because the base was originally transparent
Lucia: 但是现在不能给它们透明了
Lucia: But now we can't keep it transparent
Lucia: 就咱们剪下来它肯定是白色的
Lucia: So when we cut it down, it will be white for sure
Lucia: 哎头大
Lucia: Ugh, such a headache
Alice:哎呀我怎么红灯了快快快
Alice: Oh no, I'm seeing a red light, hurry hurry hurry
Lucia: 我的还亮着没
Lucia: Is mine still on?
Lucia: 我没充那充电宝
Lucia: I didn't charge my power bank
Alice:亮着呢
Alice: It's on
Lucia: 我一会下楼把我的线拿上充一个
Lucia: I'll go downstairs later to get my cable and charge it
Lucia: 我线放哪
Lucia: Where did I put my cable?
Lucia: 我都不记得了
Lucia: I don't even remember
Lucia: 好尴尬
Lucia: So embarrassing
Lucia: 开心打算什么时候去玩呀
Lucia: When are you planning to go out and have fun?
Alice:我在想我接下来的安排
Alice: I'm thinking about my upcoming plans
Alice:因为
Lucia: 你们是这学期课少吗
Lucia: Do you have fewer classes this semester?
Alice:对我基本上我的课都在研一上完了
Alice: Yeah, I basically finished all my classes in the first year of my graduate studies
Alice:并且我研一的时候因为我是跨专业
Alice: And because I switched majors, I had to make up three courses
Alice:我还要补修三门
Alice: I had enough classes to last a lifetime
Alice:我的课真是上的够够的
Alice: I don't want to take another class ever again
Alice:这辈子不会再想上一门课
Alice: So what was your undergraduate major?
Lucia: 哎所以你本科学的是
Lucia: Oh, you studied
Alice:物联网
Alice: Internet of Things
Lucia: 哦对对对
Lucia: Oh right, right
Lucia: 你那天自我介绍时候讲过
Lucia: You mentioned it during your self-introduction the other day
Alice:对
Alice:其我觉得自己很聪明
Alice: Actually, I think I'm very smart
Lucia: 就是很聪明呀
Lucia: You are very smart
Lucia: 因为我感觉跨专业还挺难的
Lucia: Because I think switching majors is quite difficult
Alice:是的并且我没有报班
Alice: Yes, and I didn't take any classes
Alice:我是买的书自己看着考的
Alice: I just bought books and studied on my own for the exams
Lucia: 哇好厉害
Lucia: Wow, that's impressive
Alice:对
Alice: Yeah
Alice:也没有人教我
Alice: And no one taught me either.
Lucia: 那你是为什么转成语言学呀
Lucia: Then why did you switch to linguistics?
Lucia: 是自己比较喜欢吗
Lucia: Did you just really like it?
Alice:觉得比较有意思
Alice: I thought it was interesting.
Alice:我就想换个专业读
Alice: I just wanted to switch majors.
Lucia: 哎我也是
Lucia: Hey, me too.
Alice:我就想去文科看一看
Alice: I just wanted to check out humanities.
Lucia: 我本科时候学的金融然后
Lucia: I studied finance during my undergrad and...
Alice:你喜欢吗
Alice: Did you like it?
Lucia: 嗯本来我觉得还是有点喜欢的吧
Lucia: Hmm, at first I thought I liked it a bit.
Lucia: 但是学了之后发现其实并不喜欢
Lucia: But after studying it, I realized I didn't really like it.
Lucia: 然后
Lucia: And then...
Alice:就你做的很有限
Alice: You felt limited in what you could do?
Alice:你能做的
Alice: What you could do.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 我觉得我不是因为金融很卷
Lucia: I feel like finance is super competitive.
Lucia: 然后我觉得我不是一个很卷的人
Lucia: And I don't think I'm a very competitive person.
Lucia: 我不喜欢卷
Lucia: I don't like competition.
Lucia: 就是就是
Lucia: Just, just...
Alice:我也是
Alice: Me too.
Lucia: 我觉得除非是那种就是真的你喜欢卷
Lucia: I think only people who really enjoy competition and have high energy are suitable for it.
Lucia: 然后能量很高的那种人
Lucia: And are really high-energy types.
Lucia: 他才适合
Lucia: They are suitable.
Lucia: 就是我是那种
Lucia: Whereas I...
Lucia: 如果非要卷我也可以卷一下
Lucia: If I have to compete, I can, but...
Lucia: 但是我不会自发的去卷
Lucia: I won't do it voluntarily.
Lucia: 所以如果时间
Lucia: So if over time...
Alice:就做了这件事之后
Alice: After doing it...
Alice:你可能不会那么开心
Alice: You might not be that happy.
Lucia: 对然后时间长的话
Lucia: Yeah, and over time...
Lucia: 我觉得很累
Lucia: I think it's exhausting.
Lucia: 我就算了
Lucia: So I just gave up.
Alice:我当时转专业是因为
Alice: I switched majors because...
Alice:虽然我在转专业之前
Alice: Even though before switching...
Alice:我这个专业还是挺好的
Alice: My major was quite good.
Alice:毕竟算是物联网计算机那种的
Alice: It was in the field of IoT and computer science.
Alice:我当时就觉得这个行业长久不了
Alice: I just felt that the industry wouldn't last long.
Alice:我当时就觉得不出五年
Alice: I felt that in less than five years...
Alice:他可能就要那啥了
Alice: It might become obsolete.
Alice:然后并且我也不是一个
Alice: And besides, I'm not the type of person who...
Alice:就是
Alice: Right
Alice:其实我我觉得自己其实能做好的
Alice: Actually, I think I can do well.
Alice:因为
Alice: Because
Alice:我其实如果纯看那个成绩排名的话
Alice: If you look purely at my grades and rankings,
Alice:我基本上就是第四第五的那样子
Alice: I'm basically around fourth or fifth.
Alice:然后我觉得我就受不了那种就业环境
Alice: And I feel like I can't stand that kind of work environment.
Alice:我觉得我一辈子
Alice: I think for my whole life,
Alice:让我耽误个三五年又算什么呢
Alice: what's the big deal if I waste three to five years?
Alice:我就真的需要找到自己很喜欢做的事
Alice: I really need to find something I truly love doing.
Alice:我为了一些就业的压力啊
Alice: For the sake of job pressure,
Alice:或者之类的什么别人的眼光
Alice: or other people's opinions,
Alice:把自己先安置到一个
Alice: if I put myself in a position
Alice:自己其实并不喜欢的
Alice: that I don't actually like,
Alice:位置上那一辈子都在痛苦
Alice: I'll be miserable my whole life.
Alice:所以我觉得短期来看
Alice: So, in the short term,
Alice:这一两年确实没什么成就
Alice: the next year or two, I might not achieve much.
Alice:没做成什么事
Alice: I might not accomplish anything.
Alice:但是我一辈子几十年
Alice: But in my whole lifetime,
Alice:我耽误个三五年又算什么
Alice: what's three to five years wasted?
Alice:往就是等我比较老的时候
Alice: When I look back when I'm older,
Alice:往回看
Alice: looking back,
Alice:就觉得这一点点时间根本不算什么
Alice: I'll feel like that little bit of time didn't matter at all.
Lucia: 确实
Lucia: True.
Alice:无所谓我现在没有什么年龄焦虑
Alice: I don't have any age anxiety right now,
Alice:婚恋焦虑以及工作焦虑
Alice: or relationship anxiety, or job anxiety.
Alice:什么时候都可以开始
Alice: You can start anytime.
Lucia: 虽然我现在学的
Lucia: Even though what I'm studying now
Lucia: 其实跟我本科也不是完全不一样
Lucia: is actually not completely different from my undergrad.
Lucia: 就我们我们本科专业叫经济与金融
Lucia: Our undergrad major was Economics and Finance.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Mm.
Lucia: 所以就是它
Lucia: So, it’s like,
Lucia: 因为经济和金融本身它相关性就很高
Lucia: because economics and finance are closely related,
Lucia: 尤其是是别的学校
Lucia: especially at other schools,
Lucia: 比如说对外经贸之类的金融学专业
Lucia: like the International Business and Economics, their finance major,
Alice:嗯
Alice: Mm.
Lucia: 他大一的专业课也要学很多经济学
Lucia: their first-year courses also include a lot of economics.
Lucia: 因为他是一个基础性的东西
Lucia: Because it's a foundational subject.
Lucia: 金融好像是经济的二级学科
Lucia: Finance seems to be a sub-discipline of economics,
Lucia: 还是怎么回事
Lucia: or something like that.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Mm.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes
Lucia: 然后但我主要是觉得我在业界卷不来
Lucia: But mainly, I feel like I can't keep up with the industry competition
Lucia: 然后但又不是特别想搞学术研究
Lucia: And I don't really want to do academic research either
Lucia: 所以我硕士我念的是国际政治经济学
Lucia: So, I studied International Political Economy for my master's
Lucia: 就是他相当于是一个
Lucia: It's basically
Lucia: 政治学和经济学的交叉学科
Lucia: An interdisciplinary field between political science and economics
Lucia: 但是他会其实会更偏文科一点
Lucia: But it's more inclined towards the humanities
Lucia: 更偏社科一点
Lucia: More towards social sciences
Lucia: 是那会对这个专业觉得比较感兴趣
Lucia: I was really interested in this field back then
Lucia: 去学的但实际上
Lucia: So I studied it, but actually
Lucia: 实际上你说
Lucia: Actually, you know
Lucia: 我是不是很想在这个专业
Lucia: I don't really want to stay in this field
Lucia: 搞一辈子研究
Lucia: And do research all my life
Lucia: 或者说一辈子从业
Lucia: Or work in this field all my life
Lucia: 我觉得倒也不是
Lucia: I don't think so
Lucia: 我就是喜欢干各种各样不一样的事情
Lucia: I just like doing all sorts of different things
Alice:那你博士的话你会申请什么呢
Alice: So what will you apply for your PhD?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm
Alice:还是在先等等结果
Alice: Or are you waiting for results first?
Lucia: 我现在方向都跟我硕士方向差不多
Lucia: My direction is pretty much the same as my master's
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm
Lucia: 就是我申请的这几个
Lucia: So for the ones I applied for
Lucia: 但我要等最后的就是结果出来看
Lucia: I'll wait for the final results to see
Lucia: 我满不满意
Lucia: If I'm satisfied
Lucia: 如果整体来说还算比较满意的话
Lucia: If overall I'm quite satisfied
Lucia: 我应该会去先学一下
Lucia: I'll probably go study first
Lucia: 然后再看别的一些机会
Lucia: And then look for other opportunities
Lucia: 因为我就是
Lucia: Because I just
Lucia: 我不觉得
Lucia: I don't think
Lucia: 我好像是那种
Lucia: I'm the kind of person
Lucia: 会把自己一直限定在一个专业里面的
Lucia: Who would confine myself to one field forever
Lucia: 那种就像
Lucia: Like
Lucia: 我其实特别喜欢跟我朋友去拍摄影
Lucia: I actually really enjoy doing photography with my friends
Lucia: 啊或者之类这些对
Lucia: Or things like that, yeah
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm
Alice:啊相信我
Alice: Ah, trust me
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm
Alice:你一定要在你的gap year
Alice: In your gap year
Alice:就是就是
Alice: You really should
Alice:真的很要
Alice: It's really important
Alice:要珍惜你脑子里一闪而过的念头
Alice: You need to cherish the fleeting thoughts in your mind.
Lucia: 我跟他们拍了很多
Lucia: I took a lot of pictures with them.
Alice:真的
Alice: Really?
Lucia: 就我我经常当模特或者之类的
Lucia: Yeah, I often model or something like that.
Lucia: 对然后
Lucia: Right, then...
Lucia: 不过不过我说我这人很懒
Lucia: But, but I'm very lazy.
Lucia: 所以就是
Lucia: So, um...
Lucia: 其实就算是模特的话我会觉得很累
Lucia: Even being a model, I find it really tiring.
Lucia: 但是就是
Lucia: But then...
Lucia: 我们最后把那个片子做出来的时候
Lucia: When we finally finish the project,
Lucia: 会觉得嗯很有成就感
Lucia: it feels really fulfilling.
Alice:真的就是要用自己喜欢的方式
Alice: You really need to do things in a way you enjoy.
Alice:就是一定要把自己
Alice: You have to put yourself
Alice:处于一个滋养你的环境里面
Alice: in an environment that nurtures you.
Alice:然后你这个人的潜能才会被激发出来
Alice: Only then will your potential be unleashed.
Alice:这是我的感觉
Alice: That's how I feel.
Alice:我现在觉得
Alice: Right now, I think
Alice:很多事情就是你散发出的能量
Alice: a lot of things are about the energy you put out.
Alice:就是吸引力法则
Alice: It's the law of attraction.
Alice:是的
Alice: Yes.
Alice:想要什么就会有什么
Alice: Whatever you want, you'll get.
Lucia: 是这样的
Lucia: Exactly.
Lucia: 这个星星星星
Lucia: This star, star...
Lucia: 我打算到时候
Lucia: I plan to
Lucia: 直接就是在别的什么地方粘一粘
Lucia: stick it somewhere else first.
Lucia: 让它粘性变差
Lucia: Make it less sticky.
Lucia: 然后直接往墙上粘
Lucia: Then stick it on the wall.
Alice:我可以帮你把星星给它剪下来
Alice: I can help you cut out the star.
Lucia: 啊谢谢那也可以谢谢
Lucia: Ah, thanks! That works too, thank you.
Alice:搁这吧
Alice: Just put it here.
Lucia: 这个就不用剪它
Lucia: No need to cut this one.
Lucia: 这个是一个效果图就是你可以这样贴
Lucia: This is a mock-up, you can stick it like this.
Alice:这都是合格证啥的
Alice: These are all certificates and stuff.
Alice:你记得别
Alice: Remember not to...
Alice:那你别把这个扔了
Alice: Don't throw this away.
Lucia: 好嘞我把这整理一下
Lucia: Okay, I'll organize this.
Lucia: 然后我去把头发稍微扎一下
Lucia: Then I'll go tie my hair up a bit.
Lucia: 本来早晨就想扎
Lucia: I wanted to tie it up this morning,
Lucia: 但我觉得我好像事情搞不完了
Lucia: but I felt like I couldn't finish my tasks.
Lucia: 然后就没扎哎
Lucia: So I didn't do it, sigh.
Lucia: 一辈子的拖延
Lucia: A lifetime of procrastination
Lucia: 哈哈拖延症永远的拖延症
Lucia: Haha, procrastination forever
Alice:说明你就是喜欢这样的生活节奏
Alice: It means you like this pace of life
Alice:生活方式呀
Alice: This lifestyle
Lucia: 可能是因为虽然拖延
Lucia: Maybe because even though I procrastinate
Lucia: 但是每次最后总是化险为夷的
Lucia: I always manage to get things done in the end
Lucia: 把事情都干完了
Lucia: Finish everything
Lucia: 然后就潜意识里就觉得没所谓了
Lucia: So subconsciously, I feel like it's no big deal
Alice:没关系
Alice: It's fine
Lucia: 对反正总会干完的
Lucia: Yeah, I'll always finish it anyway
Lucia: 我这个一会可以粘一下了比划比划
Lucia: I can glue this in a bit, compare it
Lucia: 放在那先去把头发扎好
Lucia: Let's leave it there and tie my hair first
Lucia: 嗯我看看他们有没有发什么
Lucia: Hmm, let me see if they've sent anything
Lucia: 哎谁给我打电话呀
Lucia: Hey, who's calling me?
Lucia: 好像是杭州
Lucia: Looks like it's from Hangzhou
Lucia: 那可能是那个啥吧
Lucia: Maybe it's something
Lucia: 可能是快递
Lucia: Might be a delivery
Lucia: 要不然怎么会有杭州电话
Lucia: Why else would I get a call from Hangzhou?
Lucia: 给我打电话
Lucia: Calling me
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Lucia: 雨轩已经把他的这个门把手安上了
Lucia: Yuxuan already installed his door handle
Lucia: 我现在特别好奇想要推开他的门
Lucia: I'm really curious to push his door open now
Lucia: 哈哈哈感觉他那个设计也特别可爱
Lucia: Haha, his design is really cute
Lucia: 我今天看到他买了特别可爱的小配件
Lucia: Today I saw he bought some really cute accessories
Alice:他们回来了吗
Alice: Are they back yet?
Lucia: 感觉应该快了吧
Lucia: Feels like they should be back soon
Lucia: 哎不过取快递这个事
Lucia: But picking up packages
Lucia: 昨天我们去取快递取了一个小时
Lucia: Yesterday, it took us an hour to get the package
Lucia: 因为在路上去了一家彩票店
Lucia: Because we went to a lottery shop on the way
Alice:因为我窗帘还没有弄
Alice: My curtains are still not done
Lucia: 你是要把那个窗帘换一下吗
Lucia: Are you going to replace the curtains?
Lucia: 还是给他上面加一些东西
Lucia: Or add something on top of them?
Alice:啊换不了
Alice: Ah, can't replace them
Alice:估计那个换的话太麻烦了
Alice: Replacing them would be too troublesome
Alice:我准备把那个原来的窗帘
Alice: I'm planning to pull the original curtains
Alice:就扒拉到两边
Alice: To the sides
Alice:尽量降低它的存在感
Alice: To minimize their presence
Lucia: 啊有道理
Lucia: Ah, makes sense
Alice:然后我那个窗帘其实不遮光
Alice: And my curtains actually don't block light
Alice:它就是一个装饰的
Alice: They're just for decoration
Alice:纱的蕾蕾
Alice: Lace fabric
Alice:蕾丝
Alice: Lace
Lucia: 我们是现在已经快12点了害怕
Lucia: It's almost midnight and I'm kind of scared.
Alice:我们的甜点还没做呢
Alice: We still haven't made our dessert.
Lucia: 昨天的提拉米苏
Lucia: Yesterday's tiramisu.
Lucia: 其实我们昨天晚上汉堡还剩两个
Lucia: Actually, we still had two burgers left from last night.
Lucia: 我收拾桌的时候发现
Lucia: I found them when I was cleaning the table.
Alice:还有吗啊
Alice: Are there any left?
Lucia: 嗯好像没有了
Lucia: Hmm, seems like there aren't any.
Lucia: 谢谢可心
Lucia: Thanks, Kexin.
Lucia: 那个字到底是应该念科是医生吗
Lucia: Is that character pronounced "Ke" as in doctor?
Lucia: 还是
Lucia: Or...
Alice:科吧
Alice: "Ke," I think.
Alice:我不在乎
Alice: I don't care.
Alice:随便随便怎么念
Alice: However you want to say it.
Alice:这是一整串的吗
Alice: Is this a whole string?
Lucia: 对那个他
Lucia: Yeah, that one.
Lucia: 本来我是想用它做水母的线的
Lucia: I originally wanted to use it for jellyfish strings.
Lucia: 如果一会有空还可以做一做
Lucia: If we have time later, we can still make some.
Lucia: 然后就是我买的比较长
Lucia: And then, since I bought a longer one...
Lucia: 然后剩下的部分
Lucia: The leftover parts...
Lucia: 就可以放在那个欧根纱里面让他
Lucia: Can be put in the organza fabric to make it...
Lucia: 变得更傻一些
Lucia: Look sillier.
Lucia: 你那天有压那个花吗
Lucia: Did you press those flowers the other day?
Alice:没  没有
Alice: No, I didn't.
Lucia: 如果有压应该好了
Lucia: If you had, they should be ready.
Lucia: 我压的不多
Lucia: I didn't press many.
Lucia: 我就压了几片
Lucia: I only pressed a few.
Lucia: 因为感觉不知道能不能压成功
Lucia: Because I wasn't sure if they'd turn out well.
Lucia: 非常感谢
Lucia: Thank you so much.
Lucia: 要是你不帮我剪的话我可能
Lucia: If you didn't help me cut these, I...
Lucia: 今天就剪不完了
Lucia: Wouldn't have finished cutting them today.
Lucia: 加上这些不要了
Lucia: Add these to the discard pile.
Lucia: 只要一个效果图就可以了
Lucia: We just need one concept drawing.
Lucia: 你觉得这个好看吗
Lucia: Do you think this looks good?
Lucia: 我感觉
Lucia: I feel like...
Lucia: 他反而给我房间又增加了一个红色
Lucia: It added another red to my room.
Lucia: 我本来只想要就是就是
Lucia: I originally just wanted...
Alice:纯蓝的
Alice: Pure blue.
Lucia: 对对但是找不到那样的
Lucia: Yeah, but I can't find one like that.
Alice:白蓝色
Alice: White and blue.
Lucia: 就是像那个我之前去希腊玩的时候
Lucia: It's like when I went to Greece before.
Lucia: 他们很多餐厅都装修成那样
Lucia: A lot of restaurants there are decorated like that.
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Sigh.
Lucia: 现在发现那种风格还真不好装修呀
Lucia: Now I realize that style is actually hard to decorate.
Lucia: 本来以为可能也没有那么复杂
Lucia: I originally thought it wouldn't be that complicated.
Lucia: 谢感谢
Lucia: Thank you so much.
Lucia: 嗯好累
Lucia: Ugh, so tired.
Alice:你现在要贴吗
Alice: Are you going to put it up now?
Lucia: 嗯我想想我现在贴也可以
Lucia: Hmm, I think I can put it up now.
Lucia: 我要下去把那个拿一个充电宝
Lucia: I need to go down and get a power bank.
Lucia: 后然后应该就可以贴了
Lucia: After that, I should be able to put it up.
Lucia: 说我房子还有点还有点乱
Lucia: My place is still a bit messy.
Lucia: 我觉得我现在这样进去
Lucia: I feel like if I go in now,
Lucia: 这个眼镜就会录到我房子很乱
Lucia: the camera will capture how messy my place is.
Lucia: 这个镜头
Lucia: The lens.
Lucia: 但是哈哈哈
Lucia: But haha...
Alice:无所谓了
Alice: It doesn't matter.
Lucia: 但好像也没有办法
Lucia: But there's nothing I can do.
Lucia: 我睡衣啥都在床上撂着呢
Lucia: My pajamas and stuff are all over the bed.
Lucia: 早上起来完全没有收拾
Lucia: I didn't clean up at all this morning.
Alice:快递回来了吗
Alice: Has the package arrived?
Jake:快递回来了
Jake: The package is here.
Alice:太累了
Alice: So tired.
Alice:是不是我的啥
Alice: Is it my stuff?
Jake:这是什么呀
Jake: What is this?
Alice:小雏菊
Alice: Little daisy.
Shure: daisy
Shure: Daisy.
Katrina: 高级屌丝
Katrina: High-end loser.
其他人：猕猴桃都5块了哦
Others: Kiwi is now 5 bucks!
Shure: 就是这个大瓶
Shure: This big bottle.
Shure: 就是原来他500毫升是卖3块钱
Shure: It used to be 3 bucks for 500 ml.
Shure: 然后一升的卖4块钱
Shure: Then it was 4 bucks for a liter.
Shure: 然后所以
Shure: So,
Shure: 大家称这个4块钱这个为屌丝饮料
Shure: everyone called this 4 bucks drink a loser drink.
Jake:哦 4块钱还屌丝
Jake: Oh, 4 bucks is still a loser?
Shure: 然后哈哈哈
Shure: And hahaha...
Jake:两个EO币呢
Jake: Two EO coins.
Shure: 然后然后现在这个涨价涨到5块
Shure: Now it's gone up to 5 bucks.
Shure: 大家纷纷喊买不起了
Shure: Everyone says they can't afford it now.
Jake:呵呵呵真屌丝
Jake: Haha, such a loser.
Shure: 有人随着风去
Shure: Someone is going with the wind.
Alice:OK了我的齐了谢谢你
Alice: Okay, mine is done. Thank you.
Alice:要不我给这拆了吧
Alice: Should I take this apart?
其他人：操这么屌
Others: Wow, so awesome.
其他人：我做的厉害吧
Others: Did I do a good job or what?
Jake:来我帮你
Jake: Let me help you.
Alice:没事没事
Alice: No, it's okay.
Jake:我来看看
Jake: Let me see.
Jake:哇这么这么牛逼
Jake: Wow, this is amazing.
Shure: 爱自己是终身浪漫的开始
Shure: Loving yourself is the beginning of a lifelong romance.
Shure: 这个很好看
Shure: This looks great.
Shure: 我要这个
Shure: I want this one.
Shure: 卧槽这好帅啊这些
Shure: Wow, these are so cool.
其他人：0.5个EGO
Others: 0.5 EGO.
Tasha: 还剩下几天
Tasha: How many days are left?
Tasha: 不就剩下两天吗
Tasha: Only two days left, right?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Jake:人均没电
Jake: No power left for everyone.
Jake:挺好啊
Jake: It's fine.
Lucia: 啊没电了吗
Lucia: Ah, no power?
Shure: 我靠这还有安格斯厚牛堡都没吃呢
Shure: Whoa, there's still an Angus beef burger that hasn't been eaten.
Shure: 对啊太败家了吧
Shure: Yeah, that's so wasteful.
Shure: 这一帮帮的
Shure: This whole group...
Jake:还有两个
Jake: There are two more.
Shure: 还有两个我
Shure: There are two more.
Jake:两个
Jake: Two.
Shure: 两个我操
Shure: Two, damn.
Shure: 太太过分了
Shure: This is too much.
Shure: 这么好的东西不吃我天
Shure: Such good stuff left uneaten, oh man.
Jake:咋办炒的吧
Jake: What to do, fry them?
Jake:要不什么炒
Jake: Or should we fry something?
Shure: 什么炒了
Shure: Fry what?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 拿微波炉叮一下不就得了还炒了
Shure: Just microwave it, no need to fry.
Shure: 可以
Shure: Okay.
Jake:可以呃可以可以
Jake: Okay, uh, okay, okay.
Jake:确实确实可以确实可以
Jake: Indeed, indeed, we can do that.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mm-hmm.